[Music]
great question I think we need to hire
people less on their IQ and more on
their EQ more on their values how well
grounded they are how good team players
they are how well they relate and what
kind of do they have the self-awareness
so they have a good sense of themselves
so that they can they understand it's
not all about me it's about we and as
long as they're hiring leaders and
putting leaders in place I think it's
all about them we're just going to have
more upsets and more destroyed
corporations it isn't just on Wall
Street that's what happened to General
Motors that's what happened to the old
AT&T we've seen a lot of companies go
down because the leadership was not
focused on how to build a long-term
institution
well I would do a much greater in-depth
assessment of his values and his
emotional intelligence sent him off for
a psychological assessment which we do
before we hire people so we're promoting
someone internally shouldn't they have
it too I think it's totally appropriate
360 feedback well the best thing that's
ever been created I made a lot of hiring
I made a lot of promotional mistakes
because I was basing them on my
impression of the people and some of
these people look very good upward they
could do a great job making
presentations they always are on top of
their game but when you have down and
talk to the people they work that work
for them they couldn't stand them and
I'll tell you that people always tell
you a 360 evaluation is one of the most
important tools to any organization yet
Goldman does this religiously and tronic
does Novartis does I think it's
essential that companies just I always
did it as CEO I got an evaluation from
my executive committee it was always
considerably harsher than what the board
said to me
well it starts at the top it's the CEOs
gotta want it and that same Davos
meeting last year I had Jamie Dimon on a
panel and he told a story about a woman
that said and went to manage my meeting
mr. Dimon we need one person on your
staff was a truth teller tell you the
truth at all times
and he said well with all due respect if
I have only one truth teller I need to
fire the other nine people I need ten
truth tellers everyone's got to tell the
truth
see he creates that counter environment
tell me what I'm doing wrong I had
people come into my office and tell me
when I was going off base off track and
they helped me stay on track they helped
me realize what was going on you need
people like that and if it doesn't start
with the boss it's not going to start
further down I think you've got to have
that and then spread it throughout the
system and the strong firms F's
resilient management like Johnson &
Johnson like McKinsey like Goldman like
General Electric have this kind of
system where they do very good a job
performance evaluation and feedback on a
regular basis and straight-up honest
conversations